BASED ON POLITICAL OR PARTISAN
INFLUENCE IS SOMETHING I'M
UTTERLY UNYIELDING ON.
>> Sean: WITH WITH -- WITH
REACTION, CONGRESSMAN ANDY
GIVENS AND CONGRESSMAN GATES.
TALK ABOUT THE LETTER.
THIS IS IMPORTANT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IN THE SWAMP OF WASHINGTON,
D.C., McCAIN WAS A LOCH NESS
MONSTER.
THERE IS A REPORT IN FINAL
REFORM PREPARED BY THE OFFICE
OF PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
DETAILING THE BASIS FOR FIRING
ANDY McCABE AND WE BELIEVE
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD SEE
IT.
BECAUSE WHEN WE SYNTHESIZE
THIS REPORT WITH WHAT WE HAVE
LEARNED IN THE CONGRESSIONAL
INVESTIGATION ABOUT THE ANDY
McCABE'S OFFICE BEING THE
VERY PLACE THAT PETER -- PLACE
THEY STRUCK THE INSURANCE
POLICY AND WE SAW THE E-MAILS
THAT SAID THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION IS NOT CONDUCTED
BY THE FIELD OFFICE AND IS
INSTEAD SENT TO HEADQUARTERS
FOR JAMES COMEY AND ANDREW
McCABE TO DO THE DEEP SWAMP
ACTIVITIES.
THIS IS INFORMATION WE HAVE
GOT TO KNOW.
IT WILL HELP US FIND THE OTHER
SWAMP CREATURES THAT NEED TO
BE DRIVEN OUT OF TOWN,
POTENTIALLY IN HANDCUFFS.
>> Sean: YOU SOUND LIKE A
ALL RIGHT ROER.
BACK TO -- YOU SOUND LIKE A REPR
BACK TO -- YOU SOUND LIKE A REPE
BACK TO -- YOU SOUND LIKE A REP.
I'M MESSING AROUND WITH YOU.
CONGRESSMAN BIGGS, GET TO WHAT
YOU ARE SAYING.
>> WE HAVE PEOPLE INDICTED FOR
PROCESS CRIMES OR LYING TO THE
INVESTIGATORS IN THE MUELLER
INVESTIGATION.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENED HERE
WITH McCABE.
SO NOT ONLY IS HE THE CENTER
OF THE WHOLE THING GOING BACK
TO THE HILLARY INVESTIGATION
BUT HE IS LYING.
NOW THE OTHER SIDE THE PRESS
SAYING HE NEEDED A FEW MORE
HOURS SO HE CAN GET A PENSION.
THAT IS NOT IMPORTANT.
IT'S IMPORTANT HE IS TREATED
LIKE ANY OTHER PERSON IN MECH.
WE ARE A RULE OF LAW COUNTRY
AND HE SHOULD ADHERE TO RULE
OF LAW LIKE EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Sean: WHY IS THERE THE
MYSTERIOUS RELUCTANCE AND
RESISTANCE OF ROD ROSENSTEIN
ESPECIALLY, WHY THIS
RESISTANCE?
HE WAS BEGGING WHEN DEVIN
NUNES HAD SUBPOENAED THE
DOCUMENTS, HE IS BEGGING IN
THE FINAL HOURS OH, PLEASE,
CONGRESSMAN RYAN, MR. SPEAKER,
DON'T TURN OVER THIS
INFORMATION.
LET'S NOT LET THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE HOW CORRUPT THE
FISA WARRANTS WERE IN THE CASE
OF CARTER PAGE AND THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
WE DIDN'T TELL THEM THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR THE LIES AND
THAT WAS SUBSEQUENT
ALLEGATIONS ON THREE OCCASIONS
AND BY THE WAY, ROD ROSENSTEIN
APPROVED ONE AT LEAST, MAYBE
TWO.
THEN HE APPOINTS MUELLER.
IF THAT IS NOT A CONFLICT, I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IS.
>> THERE IS A TROUBLING
ALLERGY AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WHEN IT COMES TO
TRANSPARENCY.
THEY ARE FIGHTING AGAINST
EVERY EFFORT BY THE CONGRESS
TO SHOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHAT IS REALLY HAPPENING.
WE HAVE REQUESTED MORE THAN
1.3 MILLION RECORDS IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND WE
HAVE ONLY GOTTEN 3,000 SO FAR.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE IN DISPUTE.
THIS IS NOT A DRAFT WORK
PRODUCT.
THIS IS A FINAL REPORT THAT
INDICATES THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF THE F.B.I. ENGAGED IN
POLITICAL HACKERY HE HAD TO BE
FIRED BEFORE HIS ESRIG NATION.
-- RESIGNATION.
TO SUGGEST THAT IS NOT A
DOCUMENT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD SEE IS LUDICROUS.
THIS STONEWALLING ERODED THE
TRUST OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND THE FOLKS WE NEED TO RELY
ON MOST TO KEEP RULE OF LAW
SACRED AND PRESERVED IN THE